foreign
for all the crap
that I get thrown at me on this app and
other places here YouTube Twitter
I think the only stuff that actually
offends me
are the people who try and claim in some
way that they're trying to help
oh what you're doing to your body is
permanent you haven't thought about this
you've been tricked you'll go to hell
that's a popular one
the thing is you don't actually care
about me
I know you don't
because you know
you're not telling me I haven't anything
that I haven't heard before
I hear this stuff dozens if not hundreds
of times every single day and I have for
my whole life I've heard what you people
think about queer people
and I'm still here like this
and you know that you know that this
will not change me
so the only reason you're doing it
is cruelty